[Aplausos]
a mí nunca me gustó trabajar
desde chiquito mis notas eran malísimas
mis cuadernos eran la mitad materia
incompleta y la otra mitad puro dibujito
yo pasé los años por el milagro de los
exámenes
qué
existen símbolos en todos lados yo como
tatuador creo que soy un cuentacuentos y
mi trabajo es darle cierto significado a
los símbolos como por ejemplo el búho
ave nocturna por excelencia vinculada al
mal vinculada a la brujería vinculada a
estas artes esotéricas tanto así que
casi fueron exterminados en el medievo
por la gente supersticiosa excepto los
griegos
los griegos esta gente cita no con su
con su patita con su toalla que siempre
andaban pues ellos vieron en las
características del búho de ver en la
noche de ser rapaz el gran símbolo de la
sabiduría de la iluminación
ahí está un no quiere ver lo que quiere
ver
a mí sí me gustaba aprender pero no me
gustaba para que estaba aprendiendo
siempre se repite esa frase no estudia
no seas burro
te vas a jalar el año los animales que
comen carnes se llaman carnívoros litio
sodio potasio ovidio cesio francia plata
veremos la raíz cuadrada 9 es
eso exactamente
y para mí para mí estaba súper claro mi
objetivo en la vida era nunca trabajar
los primeros tatuajes fueron encontrados
en la polinesia
ingleses fueron para esas tierras y
trajeron la magnífica cultura del tau
tal palabra que luego se fue cambiando
al inglés tattoo y luego al español el
tatuaje me llama muchísimo la atención
lo que pensaron en ese tiempo ellos se
te actuaban los oficios que ejercían por
ejemplo si es que eras un leñador usted
tatuadas las hachas si es que eras un
herrero pues del yunque y el martillo
imagínense lo que se tatuaban los que
ordeñaban vacas
pero lo importante a lo importante de
todo esto es que ellos encontraban su
sentido de vida y estaban realmente
dispuestos a marcarlos ya llevarlos por
toda la vida no alguna vez vi un letrero
gigante en inglés que decía ten cate
mondale we work
yo me quedé pensando dije tengáis
a quién se le ocurre eso qué
se le ocurre agradecer que es
lunes hijo se lo que se te agradece es
que sea viernes
entonces yo me marcho ofendido pero si
me quedo en la pregunta en la cabeza no
tenga quien agradece
no tienen que trabajar lunes
y dado mi objetivo de vida pues debía
investigar más
resulta que work es un movimiento de
gente emprendedora que quiere mejorar en
ciertos aspectos de su vida quiere ser
mejor
entonces cuando yo fui para para sus
oficinas en lugar de ver este montón de
gente con termitas y corbatas vi otro
montón de gente así como ustedes fritos
cansados sin ilusiones pero saben que
saben que estaban tenían una cosa en
común estaban enfocados en lo que ellos
querían ser a donde querían llegar
comprendí que mi deseo de no trabajar
iba a tomar más trabajo del que pensé
dentro de la mitología clásica del
tatuaje japonés
el coi fish es un pez que va cien años
contracorriente y al final del río
amarillo se convierte en un dragón un
dragón que obviamente no tiene que
trabajar
dada esta analogía
pues yo quería saber cuál eran mis
corrientes las cosas y los pesos que yo
quería liberarme para llegar a ser ese
dragón
si fallaba estaba destinado a ser el
mismo bagre
la sociedad mi primera corriente la
sociedad que nos dice que los tatuajes
los tatuajes son dignos de presidiarios
de conscriptos de chicas de mala
reputación si eso se decía de los
tatuados imagínense que se dice de los
tatuadores
eran mendigos gente que iba de bar en
bar mendigando comida pidiendo plata
para tabaco
la familia la segunda corriente
gente que te quiere gente que te ama
pero gente que también tiene mucho miedo
de que sufras que sufras las mismas
necesidades que ellos pasaron que
pasaron sus ancestros ellos ya saben el
camino y saben lo que es mejor para ti
la tercera corriente uno mismo
lleno de miedos de inexperiencia y lo
que les dije a mi falta de motivación al
trabajo
las dos primeras corrientes eran
aceptables eran manejables pero la
tercera corriente de esas y no existía
atajos porque al final del día el único
que se levanta y se acuesta con uno
mismo es uno mismo y de eso no hay
escapatoria
el yin yang es un es un símbolo que nos
indica la fuerza y el poder de la
dualidad nos indica mucho conocimiento
nos dice que no hay luz sin oscuridad
que no hay bien sin mal que no hay
ninguna tragedia sin aprendizaje
entonces empecé mi evaluación y aquel
que no conoce su historia está condenado
a repetirla con ustedes mi estimada
audiencia mi currículum vital
iglesia católica lugar donde había una
manera de ver a dios no sé si la
correcta pero es la que me enseñaron
ellos repartían amor y bondad dos veces
por semana en medio de hostias y bueno y
coscorrones si te quedabas a dormir
colegio militar lugar donde el único
dios que existía era un sargento de
apellido animal
al que un amigo le dijo mami en primer
curso
un minuto de silencio por él ortega
eeuu un año de vida y lugar donde
aprendí que el que no quiere sopa te dan
dos platos a veces pasado hasta 16 horas
trabajando en medio de clases de inglés
una panadería y repartiendo periódicos
la universidad el lugar donde te engañes
a ti mismo
haciendo cosas que otros te dicen que
hagas para que seas feliz por toda la
vida bueno por lo menos eso me pasó a mí
mi punto en mi punto de giro no el
nacimiento de amelia mi maestra de vida
el ser que me dio la fuerza y el coraje
para dejar de trabajar
si es super chistoso en la mayoría de
gente los hijos de tan cara a mi la mía
me quito
dos años de trabajo en una oficina
porque en realidad seguía teniendo mucho
miedo mucho miedo y también me quedaba
superbien el terno
y yo pero yo ya estaba cansado de
trabajar lo decidí dar mi salto de fe
dentro del mundo del tatuaje uno de los
personajes más importantes es el
este es un ser al que le han apañado más
de un pecado sin que él supiera
pero a mí me gusta mucho el concepto que
le dieron dentro del mundo del tatuaje
al señor el es el ser que
te da todo lo que tú quieras todo lo que
tú pidas con una sola condición de que
recuerdes que todo tiene su precio
pues decidí salir de mi trabajo y
empezar en el mundo del tatuaje empecé
mi aprendizaje pues yo creo que en el
tatuaje y también en la vida me daba
cuenta que cualquier decisión que yo
tome si es que es con buena voluntad
pues va a ser placentera y saben que es
lo mejor va a ser fácil
aprendí que el ser no requiere energía
porque uno ya es uno comienza a cansarse
cuando trabaja para hacer otra persona
que la única persona a quien puedes
dominar a quien puedes mandar es uno
mismo es decir que la única persona que
te quiere que te puede detener es uno
mismo la pregunta es quieres detenerte
no quieres avanzar
el tatuado como más de una decenas de
veces al ché guevara este símbolo de la
revolución que para unos es un héroe y
para otros un terrorista lo que importa
es lo que significa para el tatuado no
para el es la libertad el cambio la
independencia
para mi señor es el símbolo de la
revolución es el ají
porque porque un fruto tan que te cause
tanto ardor tanto dolor no la mejor idea
que tuvimos es ponerle en toda la comida
posible
nadie come aquí por obligación comer
aquí es una decisión personal única
responsable porque sabiendo que te va a
picar
sabiendo que te va a arder aún así te
pones y sabes que quieres más
piensa cuál es tu símbolo de revolución
cuál es esa decisión que tomaría a pesar
de que te duela a pesar de que te ardan
siempre vas a querer más cuál es tu ají
cuál es el ají en tu vida
un ejemplo de esto es amelia sabe tocar
piano entonces me quiso enseñar y me
dijo papá la mano derecha acá la mano
izquierda
entonces quería tomar de tocar una nota
así súper difícil y no me llegaba el
dedito alce la mano la mano derecha y
quería tocar el al lado izquierdo
entonces mi papá y amelia me dijo papá
no puedes hacer eso
al ser el dedo y lentamente acerque y
toque la nota mi hija yo sí pude
los dos abrimos los ojos dándonos cuenta
del secreto de la vida del ají de
nuestra vida nadie nos puede detener
tres años de esclavitud y aprendizaje
dentro del mundo del tatuaje y decidí
hacer mi imperio no elegí cero
elegí cero es donde yo vi que mi
vocación era la de un cuentacuentos
que mi sentido de vida era darle
significado permanente a los símbolos
dentro de una piel ajena dentro de una
cabeza ajena dentro de una vida ajena
todos tenemos la capacidad de
expresarnos pero no todos tenemos la
fácil la facilidad de expresar lo como
nosotros queremos en mi caso yo soy un
instrumento extraordinario de personas
maravillosas que quieren darle sentido a
su vida mientras pasamos por este
efímero universo
esto es un animal bellísimo pasa de 13 a
17 años debajo de la tierra como ninfa
pasa todo este proceso de formación
para que un día cuando la tierra está
exactamente a 18 grados centígrados
emerja como una cigarra adulta cual
única función es reproducirse y cantar
vea eso
y reproducirse y cantar y cantar con
tanta fuerza que la cigarra tiene uno de
los cantos más poderosos de la
naturaleza
este insecto es el símbolo de cambio por
excelencia no nos indica que no importa
el inicio lo que importa es el final
cuánto tiempo van a estar debajo de la
tierra cuánto tiempo van a esperar para
salir cantar hacerse escuchar
para ser excelentes para vivir
el tatuaje es un proceso donde agarramos
una maquinita que empuja una o varias
agujas debajo del epidermis e inyecta
tinta
los artistas como nosotros hacemos que
esas manchas de tinta formen cierto
cierta imagen que sea reconocida por el
tatuado esto en un periodo de tiempo
donde yo fijo como mecánico barman
psicólogo cura y todo esto con un pulso
de cirujano
como es posible que un proceso tan
macabro como es confiar en un completo
extraño
lastimarse la piel marcarse para toda la
vida
sufrir por 235 50 horas pagar por todo
este sacrilegio y al final salen felices
porque primero la pregunta no no es
porque la pregunta es para qué
y la respuesta es mucho más sencilla
para vivir para sentir para saber que
estuvieron aquí que vivieron esto
para entender que también existe la
construcción mediante la destrucción
cuando viaje a indonesia es necesario
aclarar esto porque me pasé 40 horas
metido en un avión así que cada vez que
tengo una conversación saco esto cuando
baja misiones ya
conocí un poquito del hinduismo y lo que
más me gustó fue exhiba el dios de la
destrucción pero no el dios de la
destrucción como nosotros la conocemos
sino como la destrucción como parte
natural de una nueva vida
ellos tienen tres ciudades principales
la de la creación de la
pues manutención y la de la destrucción
si va que con todos sus simbolismos con
todo su simbolismo nos dice que tiene
poder sobre la muerte sobre la vida
sobre el orgullo
pues nos recuerda que todo tiene su
final y que ese final es necesario para
un nuevo comienzo y emea y yo sentado
frente a un hueco donde estaba mi
televisión de 32 pulgadas y digo estaba
porque entraron a mi estudio y me
robaron
llegó a mi cabeza una frase que
cambiaría otra vez mi vida
aunque no me gusta que no me gustaría
que se repitiera yo creo que el robo fue
lo mejor que me pudo pasar en la vida ya
que comencé a viajar comencé a recorrer
el mundo comencé a conocer artistas que
yo admiraba y ahora son mis buenos
amigas mi mismo que son amigos ay mi
amor
comencé comencé a abrir que tenía dos
opciones para ver las cosas malas que me
pasaban o aprendía o sufría decidí
aprender
en méxico fui una vez y estaba tatuado
todo armadito no todo completamente
entonces el papyre va y cojo abro la
maleta y lo que veo es que me olvido las
tintas
un soldado sin fusil pero yo ya estaba
preparado para aprender y en méjico
busque a alguien que me apoyo y en
méxico fue la primera vez que conseguí
un patrocinador y este era de tintas
entonces reflexiona
la vida que decidí la vida que parecía
tan tan inmisericorde tan tan ingrata
era la vida que me dio todo medio
respeto me dio familia me dio vida me
dio mi paz
no era la familia
lo que me prometió la la oficina no lo
que me permitieron los títulos lo que me
permitió la universidad no era la vida
que me promete la sociedad para que yo
esté estable por dios yo no quiero estar
estable
yo quiero ser feliz
a veces a veces pienso que las personas
que te dicen oye que te vaya bien o sea
son los peores deseos que te pueden dar
son los peores siempre he visto muy
sospechoso estos deseos porque porque
primero cualquier hipócrita te puede
decir que te vaya bien y segundo las
personas que realmente quieren que te
vayan bien desean que tú tu vida está
fuera de problemas que tengas comunidad
de comodidad y que seas feliz por toda
la vida pero por qué
porque negarte a los problemas si es la
vía más fácil al conocimiento es la vía
más fácil al aprecio o que valoran más
ustedes
lo que les costó un poquito más o lo que
les viene fácil
así que cuando les vaya mal agarren sus
problemas abracen los quieran los
solucionen los porque cada vez que
ustedes solucionen sus problemas se
volverán más fuertes se volverán más
sabios se volverán más humildes se
volverán más vivos
como según la santa muerte
es el símbolo máximo viene su rito viene
desde la época prehispánica pero por la
magia del mestizaje ahora tiene ritos
católicos aunque no es aceptada por la
iglesia la santa muerte nos dice con
todo su simbolismo que todo tenemos el
mismo final tenemos el búho de la
sabiduría la balanza de la justicia
tenemos el reloj de arena donde vemos
pasar el tiempo tenemos el mundo en sus
manos que nos recuerda que todos tenemos
el mismo final y tenemos la guadaña que
tarde o temprano cortará nuestro hilo de
vida
las alta muerte si ustedes quieren es la
constante presencia de la muerte en su
vida pero si ustedes lo deciden es el
recordatorio que este día vale la pena
ser vivido que este día vale respirar
vale crear vale amar vale vivir
la santa muerte en pocas palabras nos
dice que todo llega y pasa
han pasado 11 años desde la última vez
que tuve un trabajo
ahora pues ahora me pagan para vivir que
les vaya pésimo a todos y nos vemos
pronto soy andrés bastidas della sera'